agriculteur 2.0 david forge 36 ans
s'apprête à reprendre la ferme de son
père mais à sa façon la caméra à
l'intérieur de la cabine
ces pratiques céréaliers mais aussi
youtube heures toutes les semaines il
raconte un aspect de son activité à la
ferme sur les réseaux sociaux
une façon pour lui de lutter contre les
préjugés mais lorsque je suis devenu un
greeter il ya deux années j'ai eu
beaucoup de questions de la part de mon
entourage sur ce nouveau métier je me
suis rendu compte que bien les amis mon
entourage ne connaissez que trop peu
finalement ce métier donc je leur
expliquais et j'ai trouvé bon que de
montrer aux autres et au plus grand
nombre
mon métier donc aujourd'hui je vais vous
montrer un petit peu les bâtiments ici
vous voyez donc des vieux bâtiments et
un peu plus sur la gauche vous montrer
des plus récents
l'idée est deuxième et si les deux pieds
sur le terrain et de manière pédagogique
il parle aussi bien des moissons que de
la meilleure façon de réparer son
tracteur une formule qui marche bien
depuis deux ans sa chaîne youtube a
réuni plus de onze mille abonnés une
réussite qu'il a eu du mal à assumer au
début prometteur appui de filmer son
quotidien quand même un peu la peur
d'une mauvaise et de la critique ça à la
critique m'inquiéter beaucoup aux
maquettes moi aujourd'hui parce que je
me rends compte que mal et les retours
sont quand même très positif les
commentaires les avis voilà je comptais
sur le net
il compte bien poursuivre l'aventuré en
emmenant son public vers d'autres
univers du monde agricole est dans la
vraie vie ils espèrent rencontrer pour
la première fois ses abonnés en chair et
en os au salon de l'agriculture
en février prochain